- Salam. I'm Jamsheed
Al-Jamsheedi, and this
is a Mideast Minute.
(orchestra music)
Villagers, thank you
for tuning in as always
from the middle east today,
as we broadcast to
you live from Omaha,
the hometown of a
number of peacekeepers.
With Donald Trump's election
win leading to worries
our borders will close,
it's time for the
middle east to realize
that immigrating to the
United States, is overrated.
(dramatic music)
The United States, a
nation built by immigrants.
When making it was as
easy as boarding a ship,
but no more.
Making it in modern
America is hard,
so hard in-fact that
immigrating to America
is the last thing you'd want.
First of all, according
to The Economist,
housing prices in
the United States
are nearing an all-time high.
And if you can't
afford to buy a house
what are you gonna do?
As Fox's David Asman explains,
it's not as if people are
trying to just give them away.
- Houses in Detroit were
literally being sold for $1 each
and now they can't
even give houses away.
- Yes, exactly.
People are trying to
just give them away.
But what good is a house
if you have no job?
According to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics
the unemployment rate in
the United States is at 4.6%
which sounds very low,
but is actually 84%
higher than 1953
which means jobs are
difficult to come by.
Just listen to this
business owner on KCRA.
- [Interviewer] Could
you use more workers?
- Definitely. There's a
real shortage right now,
especially skilled workers.
- Yes.
Exactly.
There is an urgent
need for workers.
But what good is
a job and a house
without food on your plate?
According to the US government's
National Integrated Drought
Information Systems,
droughts are currently affecting
26% of the United States,
devastating farmland and
making food hard to come by.
Allison Aubrey of PBS reports.
- 40% of all the food
produced in the United States
never gets eaten.
- Yes.
Exactly.
The United States
has so much food
even droughts aren't an issue.
But is that the kind of
country you wanna immigrate to?
One with houses to
give, jobs in abundance
and so much food we
throw tons in the trash?
(laughs)
That sounds awful.
And regardless villagers,
we barely have space.
We're packed to the gills.
You'd last a week in New York
before you wished you'd never
left the wide open
vistas you call home.
I'm Jamsheed
Al-Jamsheedi and this
has been a Mideast Minute.